[Music]
the cloud gives us great stability and
what that provides to our customers is
uptime that's unparalleled one of the
key aspects of how we design our market
services that has allowed us to be as
flexible and successful as we have is
that any service that we can make
asynchronous we make asynchronous and we
put everything in event stream queue and
that allows us to decouple the backend
services that do the heavy lifting from
the front-end services that provide
customer interaction so that way their
customer interaction isn't degraded
we're doing heavy processing in the
backend so that is one of the very very
key points to our success as far as the
scale that we have to deal with by kind
of standardizing our development process
and standardizing our micro services in
that regard and made the deployment
secure Bernays and the monitoring and
the metrics gathering extremely easy to
do and it made most things just
plug-and-play this do as a service mesh
that runs the psychic renée's and it
provides us with a standardized way
inside the mesh to route traffic in
between services and also allows you to
block traffic that you wouldn't want
coming into the network it also logs
these erroneous events so if you do get
like a DDoS or if you do get a an attack
of some kind and you can kind of trace
back and see what what's going on and
with the system at that point in time
ideally it would take some 100
milliseconds to serve an ad and that's
what we're able to achieve with we are
able to distribute our system across the
world using the cloud environment
you
[Music]